as we've talked about many times here on
the program housing you've noticed it's
getting more expensive in southern
nevada and local non-profits say seniors
on those fixed incomes they're really
struggling to pay rent and this morning
construction for a new apartment complex
will be breaking ground to create more
affordable housing for seniors which is
desperately needed especially after a
devastating fire in the area hector here
reporting live near eastern washington
with those details hector
good morning this project has been four
years in the making and we have some
crews out here they've already gotten
some work done out there this will be
the future home of the golden rule
senior apartments that'll partner with
local non-profits like three square and
meals on wheels to bring even more
services to the area we were here nearby
back in october when a fire tore through
an apartment complex also dedicating
dedicated to low-income seniors although
it's not related to the future complex
they'll both serve low-income seniors
right next to each other
so the first phase will build 60 units
for 19 million dollars here at the site
for the future complex the nonprofit
neighborhood housing services of
southern nevada is behind the project
they tell us they also got help from
city and county grants well the
nonprofit says they're expecting a large
volume of applications well before it
opens in february of next year and
that's due to the current housing crisis
for every hundred low income
how you know low low income family or
just say household there's only 16 units
available
so that's we're in a we're in a
desperate need to build faster as
developers acquire as quickly as we can
a second phase will start building
another 60 units next year it's for
seniors with a 30 percent of the area's
median income
meaning to qualify their annual income
should be around sixteen thousand
dollars for one person and the pandemic
certainly did not make things easier for
seniors on fixed income the non-profit
also told us when they bring these type
of projects affordable housing to
communities they often face
social stigma we'll talk a little bit
about that still ahead in the next half
hour reporting live hector mejia live
local now